hey guys it's Vadim with Max Tech and
like many others out there I've been
trying to find a security system for my
backyard that covers both my gate and my
shop to make sure nobody's snooping
around out there the only problem was
that I couldn't figure out how I would
wire it all up and connect it to my
phone especially since the Wi-Fi
reception out there near the shop isn't
great well I'm happy to say that I've
honestly found the perfect solution by
far and that's yuffie's new wire free
s330 UV cam 3 security camera system
with two cameras that support 4K quality
and solar charging Yes you heard that
right it's completely wire free and
supports constant solar charging
requiring only two hours of sunlight per
day to basically stay charged up
perpetually without having to come back
and charge the batteries all the time I
literally didn't know that something
like this existed or it was possible
until yuffie reached out to us to
sponsor this review you and I'm honestly
so happy with every part of my
experience with this security camera
system especially since there's no
monthly subscription yes it's completely
free month a month unlike so many other
competitors so what I'm going to do in
this review is split it up into a couple
of different sections including the
incredibly easy installation and setup
the quality of the cameras for daytime
and night time and the software in terms
of the app and the features of the
cameras now I cannot stress how
incredibly easy the installation was
since everything you need is in the Box
including the two Palm size cameras the
home base with a power adapter all of
the hardware bits for installation and
ethernet cable that connects to your
router a charging cable and manual Now
setting it all up is very simple just
plug the home base into power and
connect it to your router then download
the ufe security app and create an
account for free once that's done add
your home base as a device by scanning
the QR code on the bottom taking
literally only seconds to connect and
then you can easily update the firmware
then add each camera by simply pressing
the sync button on the back which starts
playing sound through the speakers to
connect it to the home base and once
both of them are done voila that's it
the only other thing you have to do is
get them charged up for the first time
which you can do directly into the back
of the home base or by simply using a
wall charger with the included cable now
the home base also includes a spot for
an optional hard disk drive which is
very easy to access by removing the
magnetic lid and simply clicking it into
the enclosure and sliding it into the
home base then just open the app which
by the way supports face ID login go to
the storage management section and
format the drive that's it you've got a
bunch of long-term storage especially if
you want Perpetual recording now moving
on to the actual Hardware installation
it's so incredibly easy because they
include these adapters which the camera
screws onto with a ball joint for
adjusting the angle just grab the
included install guide sticker place it
wherever you want drill two holes then
put in the included anchors and screw
down the static portion of the base
adapter and because it's completely wire
free all you need to do is screw on the
second half of the adapter and then
finally the camera and Bam there you go
it's done and because that was so simple
without having to Fumble with a bunch of
wires it made it a lot easier to install
on the fascia of my shop which is a
harder to reach spot but it literally
only took a couple of minutes to do it
and it was done and ready so I've got to
give yuffie a ton of credit for how easy
this installation was and I'm actually
blown away by how well their software
ran during the installation process no
hiccups no crashes just pure reliable
setup throughout the whole process which
is refreshing because I've used some
other software from a different brand
from my doorbell camera and let me tell
you it was and is painful at times and
now with that said one of the most
important things to a security camera
system is the app including how well it
works so before I get into the quality
of the cameras let's show off the ufe
security app first and foremost of
course we have the home page right here
showing two of our cameras and the
yuffie home base right here we have the
events tab which shows different events
that happened throughout the day like
for example when I was setting it up it
actually shows the modes I was switching
and that it was seeing a human it
literally says human right here which
was me setting it up and on top of that
you can detect everything from humans
Vehicles pets basically everything using
the bionic mind AI you can also go into
the home base then face management and
you can even add familiar faces to your
own app so it's going to recognize you
and not set off the alarm for example
just go into the albums then choose a
face which detected me right here add in
my own name say it's a family member
which is me and Bam there you go the
familiar faces and added let's actually
add in just one more where is my wife
over here there she is boom that's my
wife add her in just like that now they
also have the security tab right here
which you can switch between the
different modes and each one has a bunch
of customizations like the different
delays for the alarm or leaving and you
can switch different things for each
camera to do like for example video
recording notification or the different
alarms you want each one to do and you
can also go back in for example turn on
Geo fencing which will use your GPS
location to see when you left your house
to switch to a different mode which is
definitely cool now we also have the
explore tab which here UV security shows
off a lot of their other products
including some of their discounts as as
you can see you can order additional
things like an add-on camera if you want
three instead of two you can even order
their floodlight their video doorbell
Smart Lock alarm system and a lot of
these products will work together but
getting back to the devices tab as you
can see I have my two cameras and my
yuffie home base but I'm gonna go into
the bionic mind AI face management which
basically uses smart AI to detect new
faces which you can review and approve
adding them to the system of course
you've also got the AI empowerment which
uses the automatic smart AI to detect
things like the cars and animals which
is in beta or of course humans now over
here we have the storage management page
which you see the local storage about 16
gigs and the one terabyte hard drive
which I added in manually but the home
base will accept either a hard drive or
SSD up to 16 terabytes which is a ton of
storage but let's go back to our camera
view you and let's go over to the shop
now check out how fast this is boom that
is the live preview that is literally
audio playing oh it looks like a trade
trade is going by so I'm just gonna mute
the audio with that button right there
now as you can see there's a hold and
speak button so you could literally just
hold it and say a message to whoever's
out there hey what's up you have the
little record button right here so it'll
literally record a clip let's say you
see somebody on the camera you want to
record it tap record there you go it's
going then as soon as you hit stop it
actually goes to your camera roll right
there
there you go on top of that you have
this little scissor button which just
literally takes a screenshot puts it
into your camera roll as well and we
have some more options over here where
we could actually turn on an alarm
okay so that's going outside that's
probably really loud
I'm just gonna hit the stop button
that's probably really loud out there so
I'm going to turn it off and then you
have this button right here which turns
on the spotlight obviously right now we
won't see anything out there because
it's very bright but I tested it out
works great you also have the night
vision which you can switch between the
Black and White Night Vision or the
spotlight and then we have the little
gear icon with a bunch of different
settings you can see the solar charging
if it's working well you see the Wi-Fi
connection you see the battery you can
actually go into the motion detection
and change the sensitivity I've adjusted
this zone so if anything walks into here
it's going to give me a notification on
top of that we have the power manager
you can optimize for battery life you
can optimize for surveillance you can
even go into the solar dashboard and see
how the solar charging is working as you
can see over the past few days it's
charged up to 100 using solar alone and
then going back we have the spotlight
settings which you can set it to very
high brightness and then we have the
anti-theft detection and the Privacy
zones which literally you can see I set
up a privacy zone right there now
finally getting into the quality I'm
going to switch over to my backyard Cam
and show you guys how great the 4K
quality really is hinge to zoom
and you can zoom in live into your feed
anywhere you want and like guys this
quality is crazy crazy good I checked it
out and I looked at myself especially at
night and I was blown away by the level
of detail you can see on my face with
and without the spotlight on even the
night vision and then of course you can
just hit this button and go into full
screen mode if you really want to take a
closer look and take advantage of your
entire display but I've got to say that
the combination of Incredible video
quality and especially the Flawless
software within the app just blew my
mind everything just works you don't get
weird glitches the app doesn't crash it
does what you want it to do without
issues and that's hugely important for a
security camera system but out of all
other features it's the fact that it's
wire free and has solar charging that's
an absolute Game Changer and probably
the thing that matters the most to a lot
of people is the fact that there's no
monthly payment so without a doubt I
think the s330 UV cam 3 Takes the Cake
in terms of easy to use and install
security camera systems especially since
you can continue adding more of their
products within their ecosystem so if
you're interested in checking it out
I'll drop a link down in the description
below and if you enjoyed this video
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign